[Music]
I cannot shoot with my hand I shall give
my mind I do not kill with my gun
I killed my heart the Dark Tower
accentuate the guns things were Knights
just wanna protect us from the coming of
the dark
now I'm the other one that the man a
black morsel ruled our worlds so how can
be unleashed
you can't stop what's coming I will kill
him
the Dark Tower you were in very bad
shape I'm surprised you're even sitting
up I'm stronger than most
the war is over all trend everyone you
ever loved has died by my hand
no matter what you do
the tower will fall
death always wins the dark tower the
thousands of generations the gunslingers
were Knights just want to protect us
from the current of the dark these
visions as you call them what do you see
I see a tower the man in black and they
come steamer you just dreams
they're not real Jake if you know the
world out there others
who are you you here at gunslinger right
your are no coincidence not anymore
why does the man in black want to
destroy the tower the tower protects
both our worlds if it falls hell will be
unleashed
he's like the devil isn't he no he's
worse you can't stop what's coming death
always wins your world might be gone but
mine isn't
you let that telephone billions of
people die
guns and bullets in your wallet you're
gonna like earth a lot all right let's
go
you clawing your way out of the darkness
did you tell the kid who ever walked
with you guys by my hand
I will kill him for both of us you're
not aiming at my head
in range with his hand has forgotten the
face of his father I aim in my eye
I cannot shoot with my hands
official move my mind
I did not kill with my gun I kill of my
heart
[Music]
[Music]